Okay, so in this video I'm going to go
over TPO or market profile,
volume profile, and how those intertwine
with the idea of auction market theory.
We're going to touch on a couple quick
terms here. So, the idea of acceptance,
rejection,
and all that kind of stuff.
So, start with TPO or market profile.
So, TPO stands for time, price,
opportunity. And essentially it shows
you where market spent time.
Right? So, essentially it shows you time
being spent at each price level. So, I'm
going to briefly talk about the idea of
value here. Okay, so it's a term you
hear a lot.
And let's say this is a profile. This is
what you call the distribution.
So, talking about, you know, what I did
in the last video.
Uh I'll go back to the car analogy here.
So,
this is where, right, the the
the biggest peak in this distribution,
this is where the most cars were sold.
Um this is kind of that 31
K level. This would be the 29 K level.
And this is where it tapers off towards
the edge. Right? So,
what we call the point of control is
where the most time was spent. Right?
The most cars were sold. So, that would
be the biggest peak. And this applies to
volume profiles as well. I'll touch on
that in a second.
But this is what you call your point of
control. Right? So, we call that
it's abbreviated as
Whoops. POC.
Okay, point of control. This is where
the most time was spent.
And that is the mean. That is the mean
over the period the profile is pulled.
So, in regards to TPO or market profile,
the majority of the time they are on a
fixed period. So, for example, it will
plot
a profile showing time spent at each
price level over the course of a day,
over the course of a session, over the
course of a week, over the course of a
month.
And that's how we kind of use those from
there. So, let's say this is a day.
The most time spent throughout the day
is the point of control. This is where
the buyers and sellers agreed the most.
They they you know, they transacted the
most around this level.
Conversely, your kind of 31 K and 29 K
levels, right before it starts to taper
off, right in this distribution is what
we call this. I'll show you in a second
down the chart.
Um
you know, you'd have something like
this, and you'd have one like this. So,
this is your value area low.
Okay, abbreviated as val.
And this is your value area high.
And why does this matter to you?
Well, this is one standard deviation
either side of the mean. So, the POC is
the mean price.
And value area high is one standard
deviation
to this side of the mean, and value area
low is one standard deviation to the
other side of the mean.
Okay, so essentially what this means to
you is that
this is where the market was balanced.
The point of control is the most fair
price, and this entire thing is what we
call fair value. Okay?
So, the idea is that
within this area is where buyers and
sellers are happy to do business. The
POC is is essentially the most fair
price. That's the mean, right?
One standard deviation either side of
the mean gives you your value area,
which is fair price overall.
Okay, so what does this mean to you in
simplicity terms?
Essentially,
when price is balanced in a balanced
state, so let's say it's
just go to like a 15-minute here. Give
me a bit more drawing space.
Not a great drawing I'm not an artist
here, but we'll go down to charts in a
second. The idea is that when when the
price is price is not rotational here,
it's inside of value.
Value area high will be resistance until
proven otherwise. So, until it
significantly shows a break above value,
right? The market is balanced right now.
So, if it attempts to go imbalanced,
right?
Um then that would change. But more or
less, value area high is resistance,
value area low is support
until it breaks. Right, and this this
cycle continues as long as buyers and
sellers are happy to transact here.
So, let's say that
market breaks to the downside,
you get a retest of that level. So, from
outside of balance, value area low is
resistance. Okay? If it broke to the
upside,
value area high is support.
So, very simple.
Now, conversely, the idea of acceptance,
which I talked about kind of briefly in
the AMT video,
if price or the market accepts this
this distribution or this price as fair,
this area of balance,
you expect it to be you expect value
area low here to be resistance.
Should the market accept that price,
buyers and sellers agree that this is
fair,
and the market accepts into value, this
now becomes support.
Right? And you expect a full move to the
other side of value, where value area
high should be resistance. This is what
we call the traversal of value.
Okay?
So, very simple. So, what is a TPO?
Well, let's go down to a chart here and
I'll show you.
So, for starters,
a standard TPO or market profile is
always used on the 30-minute time frame,
being that each block of a TPO is 30
minutes. Okay? Because it measures time,
and that's how it measures it.
I'm not going to go super super in-depth
on this. Right? I just want to show you
the idea of balance and and how price
accepts and rejects value.
So, very simply,
uh TPO can be used in a few different
platforms. It is a paid
indicator or technical tool on
TradingView.
Um MMT has a free one. ATAS, I believe,
is free. GoCharting is free. KioTakka is
free. There's a handful of ways you can
use it for free.
And don't worry if if this is totally
throwing you off and you're not
interested in using TPO, you can use a
fixed range volume profile basically
exactly the same way, and it's a free
tool on TradingView. I'll show you here
in a second.
>> [sighs]
>> So, more or less,
this is what TPO looks like. Takes a
while to load. Let me just reset all of
these.
So, like I said, I'll briefly go through
this here.
TPO, like I said, you know, has
different periods. So, day, week, month
are very standard. There is session as
well.
Um So, for example, let's just go over
the course of a day. So,
>> [clears throat]
>> as you can see here, this is your
distribution. So, what I drew up here,
okay? So, here's your value area. This
is 68% of all
volume or time spent over the area this
tool is pulled. So, if this is a day,
value area high and value area low is
68%
of all time spent in this area. Volume
is exactly the same with the volume
profile, but this measures time, not
volume. Though, they are very similar
nonetheless.
So, one standard deviation either side
of the mean is 68%.
So, for example, the idea is that
where balance persists,
right? Where you have these
distributions, you can apply those rules
of the market being rotational and value
area high and value area low being
support and resistance.
While inside of balance, or outside of
balance, it's the opposite. So, value
area low will be resistance on the
outside. Value area high would be
support. And conversely, you know, they
would be flipped if the market was in
balance.
So, very similarly here, right? You can
see value area high is resistance, value
area low is support, holding a support,
holding a support until we get a break
from balance, okay? And this is a
continuous cycle. Like I mentioned
before, the market is balanced, it goes
imbalanced,
starts to build out new balance,
retests the edge of balance,
accepts back inside of balance here, and
you see the full traversal of value. So,
let's just break that down here.
Uh let's go like this. So, very
similarly, I'm just going to take a
profile off here just to show you the
idea of balance because the TPO gets in
the way.
So, you have this area of balance here.
Okay?
Right? Buyers and sellers are obviously
in agreement being that it it it's
simply a balanced market, okay?
You also have an area of balance here.
Okay?
So,
and I'm going to mark this as well
because there's obviously balance here.
Let's just draw something like this. And
I'll kind of show you how I'm I'm
roughly eyeballing these boxes here, but
I'll show you how I'm getting this
anyways in a second. And it's it's it's
the value area, right? That's how you
measure to get the levels.
So, more or less,
buyers and sellers are in agreement
here. We more or less have a a balanced
market. We get a flush lower, right? And
then at that point it starts to build up
more balance. The market becomes
imbalanced again.
You see acceptance back inside
of prior balance. Like I said, you know,
the market buyers and sellers agreed
this is fair. We will both transact
here. We're happy to do so.
And you get a traversal to the other
side. Then it starts to become
rotational again.
We get a break from balance. It retests
the edge of prior balance. Buyers and
sellers agree that this is not fair
price. We don't want to transact here.
It reverts back to prior value.
Right, it accepts back in you get a
retest of the edge. And then it
traverses value.
And it starts to build up more value
again.
Okay, so it's a basic premise of how
this works. So,
>> [clears throat]
>> what does that mean for me? How can I
use it on a profile by profile basis?
So,
um
to put it simply, it's easier for you to
interpret with the volume profile right
off the start being that it's a
two-click tool and it's easier to use, I
would say. But I'll show you with TPO as
well.
I'll show you what I mean here.
So, let's just delete these.
So, in the world of market profile and
using TPO,
like I said, it it's a fixed period.
Right, you can't change this. I can't
make this a day and a half. Well,
there's kind of a way, but more or less
it's not how you do it.
Um so, the idea is that you form
composite structure. So, composite
essentially composite it is is something
that's made up of multiple parts, right?
So, a composite for example in in the
world of of market profile is when you
merge multiple profiles into one.
And you do that when balance persists.
So, when value area overlaps between
profiles, you can merge them into one.
And you simply do that by right clicking
and merging the profiles.
So, being that balance persisted here,
these can be merged.
Right? And this will this forms what you
would call a three-day composite.
Um I
I'm when I walk through volume profile,
I'll explain how this is a bit simpler
for you. And again, you you can trade it
exactly the same way. I use both of them
together because one measures time and
one measures volume and sometimes
there's discrepancies and ways to
exploit all of that, but I'm not going
to go over that stuff here.
So, you can see I merged this. Now,
that's a two-day profile and I want to
merge it into this profile as well.
And now you see that I have a three-day
composite, three-day profile because
balance persisted there. So, what I
normally do
is I use a the rectangle tool. You can
use a horizontal line, a horizontal ray,
whatever you want to use.
I usually will pull the box from value
area high to value area low.
And I have a template, but I extend the
box across and then it marks my value
area for me. I also label it. So, this
would be
three-day composite, so I put three-day
on the text here.
Again, you don't have to do this. You
can mark it however you please. It does
not matter.
So, you have three days of balance
there.
Okay?
And this day, you know, had balance
here. It went in balance and then it
formed new balance here. So, this is
where a fixed range volume profile would
come into play, but what you can also do
with TPO
um is you can split profiles as well.
So,
you can see that we were obviously
balanced here, then we went in balance.
So, what I can do is I can split the
profile here and make this into
basically two profiles. If this is
confusing, this doesn't matter. Volume
profile is really easy to do the same
thing. Um you don't have to split it at
all. But nonetheless, I'm going to split
this here just to show you the idea of
balance rejection, acceptance, all that
kind of stuff.
So, I'm going to split the profile here.
And then what I'm going to do is merge
this into more or less this is a day and
a half because
you know, the other part of the day is
up here.
I'm going to merge that.
And then we more or less have
I'm just going to say 1.5 day. Okay?
And then up here conversely the same
thing. So, this day is still developing
and it's more or less trending. So, this
probably will not be merged with the
other ones. But these three have
overlapping
value, right? This is a balanced market.
So, these will be merged. And this would
form another 3-day composite.
And now you have another 3-day profile
here.
All right. So, let's take these off. So,
let's apply the same things that we just
talked about here. So, the market is in
two states, balanced or imbalanced.
Right?
See, the market is balanced here. It
goes imbalanced. Start to build out you
know, a day and a half or so of balance
here.
You get this big impulsive move which
was a headline news.
And at that point did it accept or did
it reject this area? Well, buyers inside
was agreed this is fair price. Okay? And
how do I know that? Well, it spent time
and space in there. It accepted and
traversed value. And it also often times
will give you a retest. So, like I
mentioned before,
value area low is resistance when you're
outside of the range.
Okay? It's support when you're in the
range.
And conversely value area high is
resistance when you're inside of balance
or the range. And it's support when
you're outside of the range.
Okay? So, if we go down to a lower time
frame here,
you can see,
right? Upon this headline news, we came
back, retested the level. That's where
you would go long, and your target is
the other side of value.
Which you can see we hit right here, and
then we actually built out new balance.
And then at that point
>> [clears throat]
>> buyers and sellers in agreement, they're
more or less building new value at this
point.
Sellers decide that okay, this is no
longer a price you want to interact at.
Excuse me.
And like I said, the market is always
seeking fair value, so it reverts back
to prior value.
And instead of seeing acceptance here,
we see rejection.
Right, so this 1 and 1/2 day profile to
the tick
rejects that level.
Not interested in doing business here.
And we see time and space put back in.
We see acceptance back inside of the
older 3-day profile.
And then we see the full move through
value again.
Right? And on top of that
being that we built up balance here
you see acceptance here inside of the
older 3-day profile.
You see acceptance back in here inside
of this profile, which did end up
forming 3 days, but it was about a day
and a half I think at that point.
And you see the full move through value.
Okay? And then at that point
this is where price would be
overextended. So very similarly to kind
of my analogy on
>> [clears throat]
>> on car prices, right? This is where you
are outside of value. So this would be
kind of that 35k price. So if we have
that distribution again
right, this is your point of control.
Most are sold around here. A lot are
sold around here too, around the the 68%
around value area high value area low.
And then you have a couple that are sold
out here, which is where, you know
more often than not it it is where
they're not willing to do business.
So, right, this is where we were
what you'd deem to be essentially
overbought at that point. Right?
Um buyers no longer are interested in
doing business up here. It's too
expensive. Price reverts back into
value. Again, now that we're inside of
value, value area high is resistance.
Right? You can see that.
It rejects it. We get even one more
retest basically to the tick of value
area high. And then we see the full move
back down to value area low.
Where it found some support.
Right? It held for a little bit. And
then sellers said, "No,
we're going to push price lower. We want
lower prices." Right? And we even got
another retest of value area low. Like I
said, because value area low becomes
resistance outside of the range or
outside of balance.
And then it breaks down from there. And
now we're back at this older 1 and 1/2
day profile.
And price is now testing that area.
Right?
It's very simple.
Let's do this one more time. I want to
draw this one more time and then we'll
go over volume profile here.
So, when the market is balanced, your
trades are
at the edges. Being that your highest
probability trades around the edges of
value, where it's more favorable for you
to do so. Value area low is the is the
best price to be buying at. Right?
Whether it's a small deviation of value
area low, maybe you go long there.
Or, you know, same thing to the upside.
Deviation of the level.
Right? This is where you want to
position. And you want to target the
point of control and the other side of
value. And why is that?
If you think back to my auction market
theory,
>> [clears throat]
>> the market is always seeking fair value.
Right? This entire area, this this 68%
the value area, one standard deviation
outside of the mean, this is fair value.
But where is the most time or volume
being spent? At the point of control.
Right? So, this is where the market is
always trying to get back to because the
market is always seeking fair value. So,
the point of control acts as a magnet.
Same thing to the downside. Right? You
go long here.
You know, you can target the point of
control. You can target the other side
of value being that when the market is
balanced, it will continue to be
balanced until proven otherwise.
The other setup you have,
other two setups.
I'm going to draw this one more time and
then we'll go over volume profile.
Say the market is balanced like this,
okay?
Buyers take initiative here. You get a
breakout of that level.
Value area high was resistance inside of
the balance. It's now support, expected
to be support. This is where you would
position long. And what would you
target? An area of prior established
value because again, the market is
always seeking fair value.
Very simple.
One more setup, basically the same
thing.
Let's say the market is trending down.
It's imbalanced. You know, it tests this
area of prior balance here.
Right? If you see acceptance inside and
they buyers inside was agreed this is
fair,
you position short on the retest being
that value area high was support outside
of the range. You're now inside of the
range, right? So, now it's resistance.
Right?
And you expect the traversal through the
other side. And you have your point of
control as as kind of a first target as
well.
Very simple. So, fixed range volume
profile.
>> [clears throat]
>> Essentially, we use profiles to
determine the idea of value.
Balance is all that exists in the
market.
The idea is that all there is is balance
and anything else is just a lack of
balance. The market is either balanced
like it is here or it's imbalanced. It's
balanced. It's imbalanced. It's
balanced. It's imbalanced, right? It
goes on and on and on.
So, let's look at Bitcoin here in fixed
range volume profile.
So, if you go to your task bar here, 1 2
3 4 5 down,
fixed range volume profile.
Very simple tool. I'll show you my
settings here quickly.
It's basically what it looks like.
>> [clears throat]
>> So,
number of rows, row size 1,000.
Volume up down value area 68. So, if
you're paying attention,
68% of time or volume transacted. So,
that's one standard deviation outside of
the mean gives you 68% right?
So, just like a TPO,
TPO
shows you where market spent time,
right? It shows you how much time was
spent at each price level.
Volume profile shows you how much volume
was transacted at each price level.
So, more often than not,
the levels are very very similar and
there is there is some differences, but
for the for the sake of this video, they
are very similar and everything I showed
you with TPO earlier
essentially works the same.
So, if you're not using TPO, this this
is a great work around as well.
Right, style, you can make your color
whatever you want. Value area high,
value area low, point of control. So,
exactly the same levels, right? Except
it measures volume.
So,
if we revert back to what I said before,
the market is either balanced or
imbalanced. So, when there is balance,
you can measure the idea of what value
is within that balance with
a profile. Profile simply shows where
time was spent or where volume was
spent.
So, essentially the way that I recommend
you use a fixed range volume profile
is like I said with with with TPO, it's
a fixed period. So, it's it's either a
session, it's it's a day, it's a week,
it's a month. You can't change how it's
measured, right? When the profile
starts, when it stops.
Fixed range volume profile
is a two-click tool. So, you can measure
it however you decide to do so.
So, let's go to let's just say the
1-hour here, maybe.
And let's pull it over some areas of
balance. Let's just start here for
simplicity's sake.
Right? Basically, it you know, kind of a
small balance here. I'm I'm going to
measure this, but any of these smaller
areas of balance or small ranges, this
this works on any timeframe. It does not
matter.
But just just visually here on the on
the one hour, right?
This is an obvious area of balance. So,
what would you do? You start the tool
and you click it from the start of the
balance. This is how I recommend you do
this if you're not using TPO.
You start the tool where the market
starts balancing or starts ranging, and
upon it going in balanced, right? So,
this break here,
this impulsive move up, you would stop
the tool.
And you can see it gives you the same
idea. So, this is your point of control
here, right? Where this high volume node
is, the biggest point. This is the point
of control,
the value area high,
and the value area low, right?
If you go along here again, this would
be another area of balance. So, where it
starts to where it stops,
there's your distribution.
Conversely, there's another one here,
more or less. I would say it starts even
here or here or here or here, rather.
Let's just measure from here to where we
got this move down.
Okay.
There's also balance here,
right?
And I would say that
you know, there's also balance here,
and there's also balance here,
right? And you can go on and on and on
and practice this as much as you want,
right? There's also balance here, here,
here.
You know, here, maybe even a you know, a
larger profile here. There's definitely
balance here.
I won't get into all of that though. But
exactly the same premise applies. So,
you can see
inside of balance, value area low is
support, value area high is resistance,
resistance, support. You can see how
much time and volume is spent at the
point of control,
right?
Usually not a trade location when the
market is balanced, right? Being that
buyers and sellers are so happy to
transact here,
you will probably get chopped up. It's
not going to provide as good of
inflections or reactions as you know, a
you know, value area high and low would
do.
Right? So, you can see again, even when
it deviated value, you saw acceptance
back inside with this wick, this retest,
and you saw the move through value.
Right? Support,
resistance up here.
Goes on and on and on.
So, market came back, retested the point
of control.
Right? It failed [snorts] to break
inside of value. You can see it gets a
retest of value area high there. And
then the market goes imbalanced.
And then at that point, buyers and
sellers start building out value here.
They're happy to transact up here.
We have resistance inside of the range,
resistance, resistance, resistance,
resistance, support, support, support.
We get a break. We didn't get a retest.
More often than not, it does retest, but
this was clearly a big flush.
So, it didn't get a retest there.
And then we started building up more
balance here.
Okay?
And we even saw a kind of acceptance
back inside of this older profile here.
Right? Kind of messing around, just just
chopping on the level. We see the move
back inside.
More or less, if you drew a line here,
which this is exactly where profiles
become handy. You can see a retest of
that level.
And at that point, you can see, you
know, the full move through value.
Right? So, profile upon profile, this is
how the idea works. Acceptance,
rejection of prior established value.
And then again, same thing. Support,
support, resistance, resistance. You get
the idea.
Um upon a break, you get a retest of
value area low. And it builds up more
value from there. So, that's where you
would look to get short, being that
sellers took initiative here, and this
is no longer what they're
where they're buying. What Sorry, where
they're wanting to trade.
Same thing.
This impulsive move. Maybe get this move
back up. We get a retest of this prior
range's value area low. We get the
traversal of value, and then we start to
build up more value. Right? Resistance,
support while we're in the range.
Breaks down.
Lower time frame retest. Could have got
short.
Same thing. Retest of value area high
resistance, rejects this is not fair
value. Buyers and sellers don't want to
transact here.
And
the market shifts back inside of prior
value and we get the full move through
value and then it starts to build up
more value here. So, support, support,
resistance and we're breaking down.
And now we are retesting this level one
more time.
Right? We just swept this low. So, now
just depends what happens from here.
So, like I said, very, very simple. This
is the easiest way to do this with a
volume profile if you're not using TPO.
Right? So, same thing. You can pull this
over any obvious area of balance. Right?
So,
I would say that would be kind of your
range there.
More or less. Right? You can see
acceptance inside traversal. Value area
high to the tick.
Right? Even starts to build up kind of
more value here.
Um
this one's a bit weirder, but more or
less multiple days would probably
overlap here eventually.
Definitely have balance throughout here.
Right? Retests the point of control,
flips value area high to support, goes
imbalanced. So, always remember the
market is in two states, balanced,
imbalanced, balanced, reverts back to
balance.
And that's the that's the full cycle the
market works in. So,
>> [snorts]
>> the the kind of summary here is that
AMT gives you the logic behind
everything, balance and imbalance,
acceptance and rejection, where value
is.
>> [clears throat]
>> TPO kind of shows you how to use that
logic through measuring time at each
price level. So,
you know, how long did the market stay
at these prices? Where was value built?
Um and volume profile does exactly the
same thing, but it's measuring volume.
So, where was volume being transacted?
Where is value being built? How is price
interacting with that value?
Is it accepting? Is it rejecting?
That's that.